now finally I'm gonna set up his out of
the way this is really the main meal of
this topic right inverse trigonometric
functions number one it's the hardest
part of inverse functions we spent two
lessons on inverse functions all of them
and then we can spend like ten lessees
lost a little bit on this secondly you
remember the reason why we're doing this
now for the extension to students is
what's the next topic coming up it's
harder integration right and one of the
most important hydrogen rules is this
investment of compartments okay so
that's where we are
let's start would you get your rule
around draw me a nice set of axes
usually let me draw 3 matrix matches we
just go from nought to 2 pi I like to do
a little more of it today so let's go
from say let's go negative 4 PI o 2 4 5
yeah so let's do sine X from negative 4
PI multiplied how many old copies how
many periods wanted me to go through in
that time 1 2 on the negative side 3
fall underneath on the positive side ok
so you draw that for me it doesn't have
to be beautiful but beating your fourth
of let's try to make it as consistent as
possible
just
people with templates right now I
totally laughing okay as you continue
drawing I should point out just in
general for what I can see around the
room come a long way mostly in hanging
joint regards I don't know if any of
your court is enough to still have like
your beginning of your 11:00 work or
when we're doing this kind of thing and
you've made some great progress so but
admittedly this is quite an official
you'll always never have to draw
something with this kind of with this
frequency and have to drop that much of
it so you usually can get away with less
consistency than I'm forcing on you yeah
okay now if you at least have three
copies of the graph on there one okay I
want you to push pins down and just look
up for something have you look at this
function okay why do sine X this
presents an enormous problem for us
right you don't need to write this but
if you recall this guy this function has
very inverse function right has no
inverse function what does it have it
has an inverse relation right when you
do your swap you're going to get
something which fails the vertical line
test so what do we do if we want an
investor out of this yeah we restricted
the domain right so when you have a look
at this that guy that has an inverse
money passes the horizontal line test so
it's inverse passes the vertical line
test and we're fine right so you have a
look at this guy and you think in
exactly the same way this clearly has
the inverse right if we were to do our
swap of variables to our reflection
across y equals x which by the way where
is y equals x
this in relation to sinx it's gonna be
because we established this on the
calculus of it's um coming right through
here and it's tangential to sine X right
so you wondered what they gradient off
like when you're looking now in your
graph and again those of you with
templates we're laughing at the rest of
you right even mine is a bit steep to
notice that like if I would have put
that there I don't think that's really
45 degrees but it should be
hey I digress I'm clearly gonna have to
do something similar I'm going to have
to restrict domain okay
now question when we restricted the
domain of this guy right in order to
define its inverse the square root of x
why did we choose this part of the graph
because we didn't have to why don't we
choose X is ready to say it again yeah
we thought about what do we want to use
this for yeah it was generally
Pythagoras right we want to use it for a
length length so positive so it makes
sense this is like the most common use
case okay so that's the basis on which
we take this okay and of course we were
paying attention to the stationary point
that's what's significant about the
boundary okay so far so good
so when you come over here it's a little
more complicated isn't it it's not just
that it's this hot or this half how many
stationary points do you see well you
told me there were four cycles right
yeah there's there's two stationary
points for every cycle so I've got eight
of them here right I have to be well I
have to not just say from here all the
way I have to start somewhere and I have
to end somewhere right and I can choose
I can legitimately choose right so for
instance pick anything again if I work
for instance to say okay here's a
stationary point right here what's that
value radians guys
3 PI over 2 right because that's 2 pi so
1 2 that's 1 a half of its entry point -
if I were going to the right
how far could I go before I had to stop
to the right every one of these is PI
radians right so if I want to go all the
way over to here
how far back to rest I've gone up to 5
player 2 right okay so if I wanted to I
could say when I could assign X from 3
PI R 3 to 5 5 to 10 are restricted it
passes the horizontal line test in this
domain thumbs up I can make that the
definition for the most if I wanted to
it's a terrible choice isn't it why is
it a terrible choice the nice numbers in
there I guess another way of saying it
is um what kind of angles are in this in
this domain 3.2 3.2 right that's how you
get all the way from 0 to PI you go all
the way from 0 to PI and then you've
gone three plan to right so you have 3/4
of the way around this circle that's a
reflex angle isn't it and that's the
smallest angle in your domain and then
it just gets worse and then you get to
5.2 it was five-pound - and my cycle
heads are as an angle that I could
measure it through mirror on my cell
chip eyes the biggest things go right so
even on that like this is as far as it's
useful so a three pound three to five
point two not a great choice what would
be a better one